PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Welcome to "Get
Cooking in Cloud," where
we share the best recipes
to apply in your Cloud kitchen.
I'm Priyanka, and
in today's episode,
we'll share the recipe
to plan for data recovery
when production environment
is on Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the last episode, we
learned about Main Street Style
that deployed their production
environment on premises,
and set up a data recovery
and backup on Google Cloud.
We also learned that there are
two scenarios involved when
we talk about data recovery.
It's the data backups
and the database backups.
Today we will talk about main
event planning, who currently
runs the infrastructure
on Google Cloud,
so the disaster recovery
environment also
runs on Google Cloud.
First let's talk about that
data backup and recovery.
They have a tiered
storage pattern
on Google Cloud with Persistent
Disk attached to Compute
Engine, and they migrate
data to a low-cost tier
like nearline or
coldline storage,
since the requirement to
access the backup data
is very less likely.
Now, let's talk about the
database backups and recovery.
They have one self-managed
MySQL database deployed
on Compute Engine, and they use
Cloud BigTable and BigQuery,
which are managed databases.
Managed databases are
designed for scale.
BigTable provides
regional replication,
which provides
higher availability
than a single cluster,
additional read throughputs,
and a higher durability
and resilience
in case of zonal failures.
They use BigQuery
to archive data,
which is a great cost-effective
storage for long-term,
since the storage
price drops to 50%
if the data does not
change for 90 days.
Best part about
using BigQuery is
that it's replicated by default.
But remember, that does not
save you from data corruption--
say, by erroneous updates.
For more on dealing
with data corruption,
or if you're using any other
managed Google Cloud databases
like Cloud Spanner, Cloud
Composer, or Datastore,
there's a link in the
description just for you.
Now, let's talk about that one
self-managed MySQL database
that Main Event Planning has
deployed on Compute Engine.
Here's how this works.
Create a VPC network,
and create custom image
that's configured with
the application service.
As a part of the image, make
sure the persistent disk is
attached for the
data being processed,
create a snapshot from the
attached persistent disk,
and configure a startup script
to create a persistent disk
from the latest snapshot,
and mount the disk.
Then create an instance template
from the previously created
image.
Using this instance
template, configure
a regional managed instance
group with a target size of 1.
Make sure the health
checks are configured
at the managed instance groups.
Configure internal
load balancing
using the regional managed
instance group as well.
Then configure a scheduled task
to create regular snapshots
of the persistent disk.
Now, what happens in
case of a disaster?
Well, Main Event
Planning does not
need to initiate
any failover steps,
because they occur
automatically.
That is the best part of
the default HA features
available in Google Cloud.
In the event a replacement
database instance is needed,
disk configuration
automatically brings up
another database server
of the correct version,
attaches a persistent
disk that has the latest
backup and
transaction log files,
minimizes the need to
reconfigure clients that
communicate with
the database server,
ensures the same Google Cloud
Security controls, the IAM
policies, and the
firewall settings
apply to the recovered
database server.
To learn more about
these components,
check out the previous
episode on cold disaster
recovery for applications
on Google Cloud.
Well, there you have it.
If you have a production
application deployed
in Google Cloud and need to
set up data recovery, then
hopefully you've
learned some strategies
to apply in your
specific scenario.
That's all for today on
"Get Cooking in Cloud."
Here's hoping you're whipping
up your own DR strategy.
Join us next time, where
we will share some more
recipes on Google Cloud.
If you like this video and would
like to see more such content,
then hit those Like
and Subscribe buttons.